I'm Jimmy phela I'm Rachel Campos Duffy
I'm will Kane and this is the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
February 10 2023 I'm Lisa Brady what do
spy balloons tell us about China is the
American public getting the message if
our public writ large is not you know
convinced that we're in a 21st century
cold war with China I mean at this point
I think we should all understand that's
exactly where we're at I'm Dave Anthony
Sunday's Super Bowl Will Make History
the first where both starting
quarterbacks are black a big deal to
Doug Williams he was the first black QB
to start and win the big game 35 years
ago I take my hand off to these guys and
and hopefully we don't be talking about
this again we don't have no reason to
because you know you only have two
quarterbacks in the game and and they
about to break that barrier and I'm Greg
Jarrett I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
the Spy balloon shot down by the U.S
military last weekend is now believed to
be part of a fleet a surveillance
program run by the Chinese military for
years sending spycraft over five
continents the truth is we think we know
what they were going to collect we don't
know
that scares the hell out of me Montana
Democratic senator John tester at a
hearing yesterday where deputy secretary
of state Wendy Sherman called The
People's Republic of China the only
competitor with the intent and means to
reshape the international order a fact
borne out in the prc's provocations in
the South China Sea its human rights
abuses its use of economic coercion is
threatening behavior against Taiwan and
of course what we have just witnessed
President Biden has dismissed the idea
that shooting down the balloon will
worsen relations telling PBS NewsHour I
made it real clear to cgp
that we're going to compete fully with
China but we're not going to look at
we're not looking for conflict there
were classified briefings for the House
and Senate yesterday with many
Republicans still accusing the president
of being soft on China including Florida
Senator Marco Rubio no nation state
particularly in adversary should be able
to fly any platform over the airspace of
the United States without it being
confronted and stopped how many
Democrats say the eventual shoot down
showed U.S resolve the Pentagon says
there have been previous incursions
during the Biden and Trump
administrations but that's only in
hindsight those balloons weren't
detected at the time it's my
responsibility to detect threats to
North America I will tell you that we
did not detect those threats and that's
a domain awareness Gap that we have to
figure out Air Force General Glenn van
hurk the head of both U.S Northern
command and NORAD the North American
Aerospace Defense command says as this
balloon was approaching Alaska he
couldn't take immediate action because
it wasn't demonstrating a hostile act or
intent I mean I think it fits with their
Espionage strategy you know they they do
some super sleuthy clandestine Espionage
and then they also just flood the Zone
with discoverable operations Dan Hoffman
is a retired CIA senior clandestine
Services officer and a Fox News
contributor I'm not that surprised I
think it's very inexpensive for them to
run these sorts of operations and with
the persistent reconnaissance that an
air balloon gives you it's clearly
valuable and look they violate taiwan's
airspace on a very regular basis this is
standard modus operandi for communist
China you mentioned the word persistent
surveillance and I'm I'm guessing that's
why they would go this route when they
have satellites they can use instead of
balloons
exactly and I think that's one of the
questions that the house and the Senate
intelligence committees in particular
will be asking what exactly did China
vacuum up with this spy balloon
um they had a massive payload there and
the persistent reconnaissance would
allow them access to mobile
Communications not just you know we
assume it's like geospatial like Google
Earth stuff but I mean it's probably uh
designed to Target Communications around
key military installations and other
things and that's that's a key
requirement for our intelligence
Community what exactly was China
accomplishing with this spy mission and
why are they doing it all over the world
I know the state department has briefed
a number of nations on China's Espionage
and you know hopefully we'll learn more
as the days go by mm-hmm I mean to the
extent that it would be beneficial to
them to be able to sort of you know
hover over various sensitive sites like
this
um what about this notion that we can
jam the signals that we can sort of
prevent them from getting what they're
trying to get once we know that they're
there
it's possible uh maybe they have counter
jamming devices like it's so that's also
just a really good question to ask you
know China has been extremely bellicose
about their Espionage I mean remember
that they hacked into OPM and stole
personal data for our government
employees they ripped off the plans for
the F-35 and stole intellectual property
I mean this is what they do and the
president wasn't wrong when he said hey
that's China yeah look at Huawei and
Tick Tock uh and then you know
militarizing the South China Sea
um and then they cover it up with their
wolf Warrior diplomacy you know
propaganda where they just lie every
every word out of their mouths just like
the Soviets did back in the day if our
public writ large is not you know
convinced that we're in a 21st century
cold war with China I mean at this point
I think we should all understand that's
exactly where we're at intelligence
officials including the FBI AI director
have warned for years about China
targeting Us in various ways including
some of the ways you mentioned you know
efforts to learn our secrets in essence
is it just an issue of the Chinese
government wanting to be able to compete
and if so why wouldn't they want to be
able to do that on their own even just
as a matter of pride
okay so first of all president XI has
stated that China wants to be the
strongest military power by 2049. the
problem for China is that they're a
command Communist economy they don't do
Innovation which is what is the Hallmark
of a free democracy like ours and so
just like the Soviets before them the
only way that China can develop
artificial intelligence and other key
technological advances is just to steal
them from others who are steps ahead of
them because they're not going to do the
innovation in China that's what you know
the greatest power of the United States
military is our free market that's what
gives us the strength to power on with
the most advanced technology that
enables our military to be the best in
the world and forget about Pride I mean
of ownership but they're just going to
steal stuff it's what they do and we
have to do a better job of protecting
that you know our own intellectual
property uh otherwise you know China
will gain from it
some lawmakers have called for
reinstating what the Trump
administration had called the China
initiative targeting Chinese scientists
and professors at U.S universities over
intellectual property theft concerns or
even Espionage suspicions that program
though ended up raising a broader
question of essentially balance between
intelligence concerns and civil rights
is it possible to be so concerned about
the Chinese government and what they're
up to that we jeopardize coordination
that can actually help us you know on
certain issues so civil rights those
civil rights apply to U.S citizens
they don't apply to Chinese Nationals
who are over here doing whatever they're
doing and you know remember that in 2015
China passed a law which stated that
every one of their businesses must by
law do the bidding of China's
intelligence service
the ministry of State security so any
Chinese businessman anybody traveling
anywhere overseas has got to do exactly
as the Chinese government intelligence
service wishes and so
absolutely I think any Chinese National
who travels to the United States yet we
need to be concerned about that we need
to shut down as we've begun to their
Confucius institutes where they teach
Chinese but they're also just throwing
out lots of propaganda on our at our you
know universities
China is using our open system against
us and yes that's the strength of our
country a wide open uh cyberspace and a
free and open democracy and they're
going to use it against us just as Putin
has but we've got to shore up our
defenses there was that case in Houston
in 2020 of a Chinese Consulate being
shut down accused of being a hub you
know a various malign activities there
are hundreds of consulates from various
countries across the U.S though should
we be paying more attention to those in
in general
well we do pay a lot of attention to
those official installations uh the
challenge we face with China though to
get back to your last point is that it's
not just the official consulates of our
Embassy in Washington it's just regular
Chinese businesses or Chinese Nationals
who come to the United States uh and
steal stuff it's what they do and I'm
sorry we have to mistrust and verify
every one of them but that's not our
fault that's the fault of the Communist
Chinese regime which is using their own
people to serve their nefarious
interests if you want to blame somebody
blame XI shinping and the Communist
Chinese government that's those are the
ones who are at fault and you know the
FBI certainly is not doing that out of
uh some racial or ethnic bias it's just
because the geopolitics are what they
are Chinese entities have also been
buying up American Farmland often near
military bases what does China gain from
um having these properties yeah I mean
they absolutely are again trying to
exploit our free and open Commerce you
know to purchase land in places that
give them you know an opportunity to
steal our secrets folks can look it up
on the internet Devil's River part of
the Rio Grande drainage basin located in
Val Verde County in Southwestern Texas
uh known for its pristine water and Echo
tourism going back to 2015 GH America
Investment Group that's a Chinese
subsidiary uh they bought 100 000 Acres
of property in and around the Devils
River Conservancy why well there were
opportunities for them to steal our
secrets because they're near an Air
Force Base
um and you know Laughlin Air Force Base
which is the Air Force's you know
Premier training facility graduates
hundreds of Pilots per year so that's
why the Chinese are doing it and we need
to prevent in my view at least
foreigners from buying respect from
criteria countries like China Iran North
Korea and Russia my goodness why should
they be allowed to buy property in our
country especially China you know the
guy who was running this GH America it
was connected to Chinese intelligence
there has been some pushback lately over
concerns about projects planned by
chinese-owned companies or data concerns
for instance with Tick Tock and the
various State bands that have erupted
um is the US government though doing
enough to not only play defense with
China's data collection of us but to
protect us from their spies and collect
their data
so there's there's two ways to protect
us one is it's a fine line there we'd
like for our cyberspace to be wide open
but when it's wide open our adversaries
will exploit it so we have to look at
Banning certain apps like Tick Tock then
we should ban it but we should also be
explaining to our our citizens why we're
doing it because it's an opportunity for
China to collect the information they
need to build out their artificial
intelligence programs but we also
conduct our own Advanced offensive cyber
operation cyber command does that and
they've certainly increased the
intensity and the focus of those
operations over the past say five to six
years and that's part of it it you know
conducting cyber operations against our
adversaries which not only disable our
adversaries capabilities but also
collect Intelligence on what they're
doing against us and that way we
understand you know what they're up to
and how we can better defend ourselves
are there enough things happening behind
the scenes though do you think that
Americans can feel secure with this
situation right now
well I think when when you see a spy
balloon hovering above our country for a
whole week uh it makes people you know
justifiably concerned that typically the
job of our intelligence Services you
know is one that is such that people
shouldn't be thinking about it every day
like your question is certainly
justifiable and the last point I would
make here it's important for our public
servants including the president you
know to use the bully pulpit and explain
to our citizens what sort of
Confrontation we are involved in with
China this Century I think there would
be value there for our population writ
large because uh when when something
like this you know spy balloon Caper
happens that does make people question
are we doing enough Dan Hoffman retired
CIA senior clandestine Services officer
and Fox News contributor thank you so
much for your time thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is Greg Jarrett with your Fox News
commentary coming up
it's almost always the most watched TV
event of the year the Super Bowl number
57 this year on Sunday in Arizona on Fox
this time the Kansas City Chiefs versus
the Philadelphia Eagles the NFC
champions are led by quarterback Jalen
hurts to even have this opportunity in
front of us it's a huge blessing and I
think it's only a testament to the work
we put in as a team every man on this
team so we'll see what happens for the
AFC Champion Chiefs it's their third
trip in four years Patrick Mahomes the
quarterback won it in 2020 he comes into
this one nursing and ankle injury he
says is getting better it's going to be
uh definitely better more mobile be able
to move around a little bit better for
sure and then we'll see on game day how
close to 100 I can be this Jalen hurts
Patrick Mahomes matchup is unlike any
other in the Super Bowl it's the first
one featuring two black starting
quarterbacks and that is a big deal to
Doug Williams you know what it is you
realize his was about to be made he was
a Pioneer playing in Super Bowl 22. 35
years ago I played in the first Super
Bowl for a black quarterback and was
able to win it and become Champions and
they even named MVP the Washington
Redskins won that day 42-10 over the
Denver Broncos since then six other
black QBs have been in the Super Bowl
Steve McNair Donovan McNabb Colin
Kaepernick Cam Newton they all lost but
Russell Wilson and Patrick Mahomes have
won you look at it realistically it
shouldn't have happened if the
opportunity was given to guys before me
you know the James Harrison Marlon
briscoes and and Joe Gilliam David made
John Walton if they had been given the
same opportunity all this we talked
about today could have been done you
know years ago but it didn't happen so
we got to go what's happening today and
we got two young good quarterbacks
playing in this game and they just so
happen to be black why has it taken so
long in your opinion we now have more
black quarterbacks in the league for
sure
well we do have more black quarterbacks
in the league matter of fact this past
season that was the 11th starting
quarterbacks in Nashville League which
is to me is it's pretty good you know in
the next couple of years I'm saying five
to ten years half of the quarterbacks in
the league probably going to be black
and I think the mine has been open a
little bit more not so much the fact
that they are black the fact that they
can play the position they can think you
know that's used to be the myth on the
on the black quarterback that they
couldn't win the game they couldn't lead
the team because they're not smart
enough and all the things that was out
there but we've had eight guys to play
in that game and all of them had to be
smart you know you can't play the
position no matter how you play it you
can't play it if you're not smart so I
take my hand off to these guys and and
hopefully we don't be talking about this
again we don't have no reason to because
you know you only have two quarterbacks
in the game and and they about to break
that barrier so we won't have to deal
with this anymore when it came down 35
years ago though I mean you had been
playing in the NFL since the late 70s
back with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
did you hear all that did you hear
people say well how can he he can't play
the game or he's not going to be as good
as the other quarterbacks did you hear
that
no I didn't hear that but you knew that
that was people
um and I'm not going to say to them some
of the media and a lot of other people
yeah that was that was something unusual
to them a black quarterback leading your
football team that don't happen but
that's the mindset of so many people but
we also now you got to get out that
mindset and look at it for a realistic
standpoint yeah race does matter whether
you want to admit it or not but at the
same time we should get over it and and
understand that what is happening on
Sunday is the fact that that's what
America looks like Patrick Holmes has
been terrific ever since he came into
the league I mean a lot of people think
he's the best quarterback in the NFL
that's Up For Debate you never know you
know some people like other guys but
Jalen hurts has suddenly rushed onto the
scene as well and I say rush because he
is uh he's set a record with touchdowns
as a rushing quarterback he could also
throw the football the positions change
some since you played right Doug well
let me say this about Jalen you know um
Jalen had reinvented himself showing
people that he's capable of throwing the
ball from the pocket now what the rush
part of it put a lot of pressure on the
other team defensive coordinator and
plus he got offensive line that he feel
comfortable with so at the end of the
day you you got two guys who are capable
of beating you from the pocket but also
if you don't watch out they can beat you
with their legs Patrick Mahomes is
really a very difficult quarterback to
stop because because his scrambling
ability is a little different he does
these things this like he'll flick the
football in a certain way or throw it in
a certain way or that guys didn't do
before
when Patrick Mahone been I mean he don't
even amaze me no more it ain't even you
don't even look at it that's ordinary
football game when Patrick plays in it
because they've been doing that for the
last five years and I think what it
tells you about Patrick he's always a
thinking quarterback I mean I saw
another day rolled to his left they was
about the second he throws it and left
put it in his left hand and throw it out
in the flat you know things like that
don't happen most quarterbacks want to
look a place to fall and try to protect
the football but Patrick McComb is a
different individual but but he's all
around whatever you want his arm Talent
is so much different because he can
tweak his arm any way you you can
imagine to throw the football and he
threw it with accuracy you you played
and won a championship with the Redskins
now the commanders you you're an advisor
to the commanders so you'd think you're
an NFC guy rooting for the Super Bowl
this this time around but Philadelphia
is also a division rival
do you have a rooting interest
no my thing is the way I look at this
whole situation uh I can't win I've
already won you know and my job is not
just to watch two young
quarterbacks in the NFL do it out in the
Super Bowl who just happened to be black
I'm not gonna pull for anybody take us
back to your trip to the Super Bowl 35
years ago
what's it like to be there you're the
starting quarterback of an NFL team and
you're about to you're getting ready for
the Super Bowl what is it like
well I think I think you hit the nail on
the head when you say starting
quarterback and you know my whole
mentality that whole week
was not about me being black I made sure
that I didn't get caught up in that
because I could have easily got caught
up in being black I knew I knew what
color I was nobody had to tell me that
but but the fact that my job was to be
the quarterback of the Washington
Redskins and to execute I made sure
during the game that was my whole total
picture is that you are the quarterback
now who just happened to to be black how
hard is it to focus on the game itself
the Super Bowl is such a big event as a
player is it hard or was it easy to put
a laser focus and block it all out I I
think you you say that it's a big event
but remember this the players got to
remember this the event ain't for you
the event for Corporate America you know
how many parties they have around the
Super Bowl everybody got a party yeah
and The Party Ain't for the players
your job is to go to practice meet the
media go to the meeting study the
Playbook go to bed wake up the next day
and do the same thing so that let you
know that ain't for you
on Sundays there's a football game
that's going to be played and you got to
face that just like you face any any
other game the 17 to 16 weeks before the
Super Bowl talk about the game what was
it like yeah you you're playing Denver
you're down 10 nothing
take us back to that
well you know what the game itself you
know first of all that Saturday before
the game you know I had a I had a root
canal oh I didn't I didn't practice that
Saturday ouch so but I was fortunate
enough not to have any pain on Sunday
and um the game was the most important
thing
and you know when we went out that whole
week we had a great week of practice
physically we we knew we was the better
football team and the biggest play of
the game to be honest with you was the
fact that we recover the former that we
fumbled when they kicked off tour the
next time
drinking Sanders foaming on the kickoff
but we were fortunate enough to get the
ball back and that kept us from being
down maybe 17 nothing even 13 nothing
yeah because that that was down 17
nothing maybe there's a mental
difference like uh yeah it's been a big
mental difference yeah yeah we got the
ball back
the first quarter nothing was going
right I'm looking at Gary Clark to my
left side hit him in the hand and he
dropped the ball which you don't usually
do and I went back to pass and I slipped
and hyper extended my knee didn't know
whether or not I was gonna come back in
so I told the trainer don't touch me if
I stand up and walk off the field I was
gonna finish it yeah and um that
happened I went to the sideline came
back kicked the ball to Denver they
couldn't do anything with it they
punished the us we got the ball on the
20-yard line and the very next play you
know Ricky Sanders for 80. and at that
particular time we we had a ball game
and it's amazing how we did it you know
second quarter we had 18 plays only 18
plays we was able to score 35 points
that's a team play that's amazing and of
course you threw four touchdown passes
no one had ever done that before in one
quarter of the Super Bowl yeah I think
if one of the people people always asked
me were you in a Zone well you know what
it's hard for one individual to get in
the zone I think the whole team was in a
zone so you win the game you're the MVP
you set a record with 340 yards passing
you're on top of the world that had to
be
an amazing moment
well it was a moment that I think every
player
in the National Football League won't
you know Tom Brady had a seventh time
well he's different he's not the
hemisphere
yeah but but I don't care who you are
one time one time you got to get that
you know you know it's hard to explain
and for me walking out there as the
first black quarterback to play in the
Super Bowl and to win it uh you know so
many things went through my mind you
know I thought about the people who
doubted me uh some of the harsh things
they said during that time I thought
about the guys that did not get the
opportunity that I had uh I I thought
about everything and you know I was
fortunate enough to walk on the field
and walk into coach Robinson you know
where we both in the tunnel we both
hugged each other and cried and and
things like that and he told me he said
hey you don't even understand he said
you too young and I was 32 at that time
when he told me you're too young to
understand and Coach Rob said and the
other part is was the fact that I got up
off the turf when I got hurt he said
Hellcat you didn't stay down you got a
bus to church and he was happy about
that
so one last time Jalen hurts or Patrick
Mahomes who do you think is going to win
and maybe be the MVP
Patrick and Jalen I knew I wasn't going
to get an answer but I I had to try uh
listen I'm sure I really appreciated uh
spending some time with you
congratulations again 35 years later for
your Super Bowl win as MVP and Doug
Williams now the senior advisor to the
team president for the Washington
commanders a real honor to talk to you
thank you so much thanks for having me
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
David baligan is just nine years old but
instead of being in the fourth grade
like most kids his age he's already
finished high school he has become the
youngest student to graduate from reach
Cyber Charter School based in Harrisburg
which offers accelerated pacing online
courses he has the accolades that go
with his accomplishment too by getting
the 2022 distinguished student award
from the Pennsylvania Association of
gifted education maligan will receive
his diploma in June with the other
graduates but has already started taking
college level courses and says he's
considering a career in either
engineering chemistry or software
development Tanya J Powers Fox News
foreign
meteorologists and the worldwide
resources of fox in your hands with the
fox weather podcast precise personal
powerful subscribe and listen now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary Greg Jarrett what's
on your mind former top Twitter
Executives who censored the hunter Biden
laptop story in advance of the 2020
presidential election finally admitted
on Wednesday it was wrong to do so that
was their testimony during a contentious
hearing conducted by the house oversight
committee the story published by the New
York Post was accurate and the laptop's
incriminating contents were real its
suppression by social media companies
including Twitter may have helped Joe
Biden get elected reams of evidence
presented at the hearing revealed how
the FBI worked in concert with Twitter
to kill the story the committee
subpoenaed James Baker a key witness he
once served as general counsel for James
comey's FBI but then he joined Twitter
several months before the election Baker
you'll recall was instrumental in
pushing the Russia collusion hoax in a
lawless effort to drive Donald Trump
from office but during the hearing Baker
falsely portrayed himself as the voice
of reason who urged caution in censoring
the story not true internal emails and
other documents disclosed as part of the
Twitter files show that the opposite is
the case he dismissed the laptop as
hacked and the contents as fake while
arguing in favor of killing the story
unlike Baker the company's head of trust
and safety Joel Roth was far more candid
in his testimony when asked if he
believed the laptop was Russian
disinformation he replied I didn't then
and I don't now
when the story emerged on October 14
2020 Roth argued it didn't violate any
of Twitter's policies and should not be
censored but he was overruled by
Executives above him and that's where
Baker played an instrumental role
Ralph was already on record and sworn
declaration saying that the FBI was
behind the social media censorship every
day the bureau was sending requests
demands if you will to terminate tweets
Shadow ban conservatives and banish
accounts they just didn't like in other
words the FBI was closely collaborating
with Twitter to diminish the Free Speech
rights of millions of people
representative Jim Jordan noted during
the hearing that Twitter got played by
the FBI well they certainly did but
deliberately so representative Pete
Sessions remarked that Twitter got
caught and Twitter got bought he's right
Smoking Gun documents show the FBI
shelled out 3.5 million dollars in
taxpayer money for the company to
process its so-called moderation
requests there's nothing silly the word
one Democrat used about Congress
investigating government corruption
involving the president's family and
maybe the president himself the
committee chair James Comer pointed all
of this out when he explained that the
laptop Harbors evidence that Joe Biden's
son reaped millions of dollars from
America's adversaries emails witness
statements other records suggest the
father was complicit in the quote Biden
family influence peddling Comer
concluded National Security may be
compromised whether America's security
is in Jeopardy is certainly worth
investigating I'm Greg Jarrett Fox News
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from Fox News for Amazon
Alexa just say Alexa play news from fox
in Fox News it's the latest when you
need it on demand from Fox News and
Amazon Alexa